yeah i mean we gave it all we had on the
day um
maybe another day it would have been
different but um i think we can be we
can be proud of the way we rode
it was a really tough route to get to
this final like
yesterday semi-final we had less than 24
hours till we
till we raced this final and um you know
even getting through it was tough so
yeah we have to be pleased with the way
we rode
and paulie we've been explaining kind of
everything that you two have been
through over the last few years and
you've kind of seen the pandemic up
close and personal and
all the sacrifice and heartache that
that's had by working on the wards in
livingston
just tell me what that meant to you just
getting to the starting line of that
final
yeah i think it just gives you a huge
amount of perspective when you see
what our country has been through and i
think for me
taking that time out of the sport and
going back to the nhs was quite
important as a personal journey
and i was really pleased to be this tiny
tiny cog in this huge machine
but i think also just feeling the
support from not only my nhs colleagues
but you know everyone around the country
has been
un overwhelming and unbelievable um
and i think we probably both felt that
on the start line today
and and it makes it feel all that extra
special that
there has been that support and so many
people have reached out and helen
you've been talking about the decision
to come back into rowing after having
three children including twins which
i know kind of from a dad's point of
view is a hard thing to do
just tell me what was going through your
mind through that final were you
thinking of the kids back home or
yeah i definitely thought of them at the
start line i mean i kind of think you
end up thinking of them in
everything you do and that's why this
journey's been so different um
every stroke i took before london and
before rio was thinking about
gold and outcome and this time it's been
about journey
about getting home in time for their nap
time about you know
what time their next snack is and what
time bedtime is and fitting rowing
around life
and um so yeah it changes again like
like polly was saying about the
pandemics
changing your perspective so just being
a parent and i think that um
making them proud but also having them
part of my journey was always really
important to me there's four
extraordinary women
on team gb looking for that third
consecutive goal with charlotte
of course got a bronze charlotte
duchardan in the equestrian
and uh jay jones didn't quite do it in
taekwondo but laura kenny
she's still got the chance yeah and i
mean we'll all be rooting for her as
well i think it's um
it's fantastic to even have so many
women talking about making that accolade
i think is
is great